hey this is really really funny let me
give you the quick background remember
when Donald Trump implied that there had
been something terrible that happened in
Sweden that justified the Muslim
immigration ban he said did you see what
happened in Sweden last night turns out
he got that from Fox News Bill O'Reilly
on Fox News then invited on a so called
Swedish national security expert named
Nils built to talk about how bad
immigrant crime is in Sweden people
started looking into built and as I
reported to you a couple of weeks ago
nobody in Sweden who's actually a
national security expert had heard of
him and it turns out he hadn't even
lived in Sweden for more than two
decades and then it was revealed that
Nils built actually is one of these
criminal immigrants who came to the
United States and was charged and
convicted of I think two or three
different crimes as we told you last
week so this is where it starts getting
interesting
he started slamming me and the David
Pakman show on Twitter for the report
that we did about him and unfortunately
I don't have all the tweets because he
deleted some of them before I was able
to screenshot them but let's go through
some of what happened on Twitter after
we tweeted out that we did a report
about Neil's and Nils built okay so it
started with our tweet saying Nils bil
railed against criminal immigrants
during his Fox News appearance yet he is
a criminal
immigrant himself so he tweeted back to
us first yes why is that a critical
problem and then also tweeted said the
man whose only argument is a per
definition fallacy and he links to the
wikipedia page for the appeal to
hypocrisy fallacy also knew known as the
- Koch a fallacy and what I responded to
him was you're completely right that
would be fallacious if that was of
course the subject of our of our piece
but we were merely exposing the hilarity
of the situation not making an argument
so let's pause here for a second we were
not actually pointing out that the
reason the entire situation is bogus is
because he's guilty of the same thing
he is calling a problem in other words
immigrants going to other countries and
committing crimes we were mentioning
that as part of the overall hilarity of
the way in which this guy has appeared
out of seemingly nowhere as a national
security expert and commented about the
stuff he's completely right that if our
critique was merely an appeal to
hypocrisy it would be logically
fallacious but that's not what we were
doing and it's hilarious that he created
a Twitter account very recently has 50
followers and chooses to go after me
I mean if we were discrediting the
content based on the very fact that he
was a criminal immigrant himself he
would be right to make that argument but
that's not what we were doing no in fact
a lot of the story was about the fact
that he is not an expert in the field
which Fox News claimed he is an expert
in and then I think I sent there's there
were a couple tweets that I don't have
because he deleted them but he said
something like you've exposed yourself
by doing this story about me to which I
replied to Neal's build there's no
shortage of people who have been exposed
by this incident I believe we are quite
low on that list it's sort of sad that
this is what this guy is known for right
because if you actually look at his
background basically he exists on the
Internet as the guy known for showing up
on Fox News to appear to defend bogus
comments from Trump with a title below
him that does not even reflect his
actual expertise it's sort of sad that
that's how he's known I mean that's why
his Twitter profile picture is him on
Fox News and he only joined Twitter a
month ago
yeah seemingly after he made that
appearance yes indeed yes indeed so
there it is I was attacked by Neal's
built for our completely factual report
about Gamefly is sort of like Netflix
for video games they have over 8,000 new
and classic games for xbox one Xbox 360
ps4 ps3 Wii and a bunch of other
platforms and you can play as many games
as you want for one monthly fee and if
you find some games you want to keep you
can buy them for a low used price
there's never any due dates or late fees
and our audience can get a free 30-day
trial at Gamefly offered
hum /t DPS the games are shipped
directly to you with return envelopes
included there's no contracts and you
can rent games through the mobile app
get the free 30-day trial for the David
Pakman show audience and support our
show by going to Gamefly offer.com slash
TDP s